ken keys novel one flew over the
cuckoo's nest
introduced the world to a cast of
colorful mental patients
as well as nurse ratched the cruel
administrator who kept them in line
but also inspired an oscar-winning movie
from the stars to the side characters
here's what happened to the cast of one
flew over the cuckoo's nest
louise fletcher won an oscar for her
portrayal of the villainous nurse
ratchet and her performance is so iconic
that the character has been synonymous
with sadistic authority figures ever
since
however one flew over the cuckoo's nest
was actually what kickstarted louise
fletcher's return to acting
she'd already found some success on tv
and classics like maverick the
untouchables and the original perry
mason
however as she explained to the new york
times the imposed height that made her
so powerful as ratchet
actually held her back in those years
she explained no television producer
thought a tall woman could be sexually
attractive to anybody
i was able to get jobs on westerns
because the actors were even taller than
i was
in 1964 she took a decade off from
acting to focus on raising her kids
when she returned in thieves like us
that movie teamed her up with one of the
era's great directors robert altman
and some of its biggest stars like
shelley duvall and then of course she
made one flew over the cuckoo's nest the
following year which became her landmark
movie
some of her other roles include mrs
mccouch and the sci-fi chiller invaders
from mars
and the grandmother in the 1987
adaptation of trash classic
flowers in the attic more recently she's
appeared as rosie and netflix's girl
boss
the streaming giant is also home to the
series ratchet an original story for the
character fletcher made famous
and a prequel of sorts to cuckoo's nests
starring sarah paulson
his role as anti-hero rp mcmurphy won
jack nicholson his first of three oscars
but had already been toiling in
hollywood for years by that point
after turning down an animation job for
scooby-doo studio hannah barbera
young jack nicholson went to work for
roger corman the year as king of low
budget filmmaking
in between acting jobs he wrote the trip
for actors peter thunder and dennis
hopper
who'd scored nicholson his first big
role in easy rider
soon nicholson became the face of a new
generation of filmmakers and stars
with roles in classics like five easy
pieces chinatown
and of course one flew over the cuckoo's
nest nicholson got his most iconic role
six years later in the shining as jack
torrance an alcoholic driven to kill his
family by the evil influence of the
overlook hotel some of his other films
include a few good men
the departed and batman he's racked up a
record 12 oscar nominations
more than any other actor in history he
continued acting until 2010s how do you
know which reunited him with james l
brooks the director had led him to
oscars with terms of endearment and as
good as it gets
since then nicholson has been retired
but he's left fans of no shortage of
films to catch up on
ken keysi's original novel was narrated
not by mcmurphy but by another patient
the silent chief while the native
american inmates didn't have quite as
big a role in the movie
will samson's performance still made his
character memorable
samson came to film from a career in
rodeo that lasted 20 years
when one flew over the cuckoo's nest
producers saw him perform they realized
the six foot seven cowboy was perfect to
play the monumental chief samson
continued acting for most of his life
some of his biggest roles include a
medicine man in poltergeist ii
acting opposite clint eastwood in the
outlaw josie wales
a regular tv gig in the detective show
vegas and a starring role in the
canadian drama fishhawk
but hollywood has never been kind to
native americans but samson at least has
done his part to change that
in 1979 he helped found the american
indian registry for the performing arts
an organization that continues to help
actors and other artists to this day
but his first love was always painting a
career he continued until his death in
1987.
billy bibbitt is a shy younger man who
survived multiple suicide attempts but
is tragically undone by raptured
psychological warfare
cuckoo's nest director milos forman got
actor brad joe after role after spotting
him on stage in woodstock new york
this was the beginning of durov's film
career and he went on to play the lead
in john huston's adaptation
of flannery o'connor's wise blood he
appeared in june where he met david
lynch
who would later cast him in blue velvet
but his most iconic role was about as
far from poor innocent billy as you
could get
in child's play he appeared as serial
killer charles lee ray
who transferred his soul into a doll to
become chucky dereth would continue to
play chucky in six more films over the
next 30 years
and he's on track to return to the role
in a tv series in 2021 he even got to
call back to his earlier role as billy
in cult of chucky which saw him
terrorize a mental hospital
he describes as a cuckoo's nest while
chucky was a voice role that mostly kept
derek's face out of sight
viewers will still recognize him from
his role as sauron slimy toady gremo
worm tongue in the lord of the rings
series
despite his nebbish appearance sydney
lasik had a rugged history
serving in the u.s navy during world war
ii when he returned to civilian life he
began acting
appearing in various minor roles in
minor movies before his breakthrough as
charlie cheswick and one flew over the
cuckoo's nest
after that he was able to score bigger
projects most famously as a high school
teacher in brian de palma's classic
adaptation
of stephen king's horror novel carrie
the horror genre was good to him
elsewhere in his career as he'd scored
major roles in chillers like the unseen
and alligator
he also appeared on some tv classics
including amazing stories hawaii 5-0
knight court and the x-files later he'd
re-teamed with cuckoo's nest director
milos forman for a cameo in man on the
moon
lasik was also one half of the old
couple who rapper vanilla ice stayed
with and his legendary embarrassing star
vehicle
called as ice but we have to imagine
lasik would prefer we don't say too much
about that
playing max one of the least compliant
patients was a breakout role for a young
christopher lloyd though it had a fairly
successful stage career before one flew
over the cuckoo's nest
this was his first film role and it
launched him into a screen career that
continues to this day
while he hasn't been as prolific as
coast styles like jack nicholson
he's shown a key eye for iconic roles
and nostalgic classics that have been
seared into the brains of generations of
kids
from the 80s on up the most notable of
these roles of course was the eccentric
inventor doc
brown in the back to the future series a
party owned so completely that it's hard
to watch one flew over the cuckoo's nest
without expecting him to bust out his
catchphrase
but that doesn't mean he doesn't have
range at least as many viewers will
recognize him as a far less lovable
character
the terrifying judge doom from who
framed roger rabbit some of his other
classic parts include
uncle fester and the adams family movies
a klingon commander in star trek
iii the search for spock and even
stranger alien in the colts classic the
adventures of buckaroo bonsai across the
eighth dimension
and the zombified rasputin in anastasia
berta's longest running role was jim on
taxi
playing the self-proclaimed living
embodiment of the 60s for half a decade
and winning an emmy in the process
looking incredibly young
danny devito plays martini a relatively
minor role by someone who'd proved
himself to be a major talent in the
following decades
he re-teamed with jack nicholson for
terms of endearment and followed up
nicholson's batman role as a joker by
playing the penguin and batman returns
this began a long collaboration with
batman director tim burton
that includes films like mars attacks
big fish and dumbo and with joyce seems
to end up with devito back in the
penguins trademark top hat
some of his other recognizable roles
include his sleazy supporting turns in
crime dramas
like heist and la confidential and the
adventure duology romancing the stone
and jewel of the nile he's also had a
successful voice acting career
playing iconic animated characters like
the villain of space jam
a title role in the lorax and phil the
trainer in disney's hercules
more recently he's played spencer's
grandpa in jumanji the next level
the vetoes also found success behind the
camera he's directed seven
films including death to smoochie the
war of the roses and the family classic
matilda but devito found perhaps his
most iconic role on his always sunny in
philadelphia after a guest appearance in
2006 as frank reynolds
self-proclaimed trashman and the stepdad
of main characters dennis and d
he joined the gang of regulus where he
stayed the past 14 years i mean there's
gonna be some changes around here
understand
one of chief and mcmurphy's most
prominent ward maids is dale
a middle-aged man who does what little
he can to maintain some kind of order
when ratchet isn't around
he's played by william redfield a
veteran stage actor been acting since he
was 9 years old
entertainment was a family business for
him his father was a conductor and his
mother was a chorus girl whose resume
included broadway's legendary zigfield
follies
redfield had a successful stage career
in his own right acting in plays by
everyone from shakespeare to cole porter
he
even originated the role of psych
crowell thought in wilder's classic our
town
he also appeared in a number of beloved
movies including the fists of charles
bronson's crook killing sprees and death
wish
and the sci-fi classic fantastic voyage
his role in one flew over the cuckoo's
nest could have catapulted him to even
greater heights but tragically
it didn't work out that way redfield was
diagnosed with leukemia during filming
and he passed away two years later
in one memorable scene mcmurphy bribes
an orderly to let him throw a christmas
party
horror fans will immediately recognize
the elderly as scat man kruthas who had
a much less amicable relationship with
jack nicholson in the shining where
kratos played dick
the head chef at the overlook hotel but
kratos had a career that went far beyond
either of these roles before he took up
acting he spent 20 years as a
multi-instrumentalist and vocalist
touring the jazz circuit he told the new
york times that he took his stage name
when a radio director in dayton ohio
said that he needed something snappier
than benjamin sherman cruthers
so krueth told the director to call him
scatman because he did a lot of scat
singing at the time he made his screen
debut in 1948 on latv's dixie showboat
as the first black performer broadcast
in the city many years later he had a
recurring role on the classic sitcom
sanford and son and he was a regular on
chico and the man
but you won't recognize his face in some
of his most recognizable roles
he starred as a kung fu fighting canine
in the classic cartoon hong kong phooey
and he played supporting parts in
transformers as jazz and in disney's
aristocats where he returned to his jazz
roots to lead the musical set piece
everybody wants to be a cat
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one